we might finally have some understanding
of when to expect Grand Theft Auto 6 and
if you thought it was going to hit
around the 10-year anniversary of GTA 5
this September think again according to
reputable GTA Lee contest 2 the
long-awaited game is aiming for a
holiday 2024 launch however they claim
the goal for releasing the game has been
shifted several times in the last few
years and that it wouldn't be a surprise
if the game were to be delayed further
into 2025. Test 2 also speculates that
content intended for the main game could
be cut down for DLC down the line in
order to get the game out earlier if
this were to happen it would be a big
departure from Rockstar's rollout of GTA
5 which saw and continues to see
additional content being added to its
online multiplayer but saw Zero new
single player content after releasing
nearly 10 years ago according to the
outlet Insider gaming this information
is in line with what it heard and both
it and Tess too believe that it is
highly likely Rockstar will provide the
official first information regarding the
project before the end of this year
inside gaming goes on to say it sources
share that part of the reason for such a
long wait has to do with the fact that
GTA 6 will only launch on current
Hardware I.E PS5 and Xbox series X and S
consoles in order to be the massive hit
that the parent company take to is
looking for it wants to make sure the
install base for those systems is in a
position to accommodate tens of millions
of units for some context GTA 5 launched
on PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360 literal
months before the release of PS4 and
Xbox One meaning the install base for
both those consoles was pretty much set
in stone GTA 5 would then go on to
re-release on the then next gen Hardware
a year later since then it has become
the second best selling game of all time
behind Minecraft in contrast to the
series prior entry GTA 4 which released
early in the PS3 and Xbox 360 life
cycles moved around a seventh of the
unit's GTA 5 did and continues to do in
fact it sold even less than its
predecessor GTA San Andreas which
released on the PS2 and original Xbox at
the tail end of their life cycles in
short Take 2 is looking to ultimately
have GTA 6 be more of a GTA 5 than a GTA
4 in terms of sales and if there's more
Hardware in consumers hands at the time
of launch that is an easier task to
accomplish of course what could throw a
wrench in the works when it comes to the
sales of GTA 6 is if it were to launch
on Xbox game pass but let's be honest
the only chance there is of that
happening is if Microsoft were to buy
Rockstar which they can't do can they
some games that are coming to Xbox game
pass this month speak to a wide variety
of players into fighting games the
popular Guilty Gear strive is available
today through the service what about
survival or strategy games 2021's
incredibly popular survival PC title
valheim will make its console debut via
the service on March 14th while the
strategy game civilization 6 will come
to both console and PC two days later on
March 16th or maybe RPGs or moyo Jam if
so you'll be happy to hear that the
delightful ninokuni 2 Revenant Kingdom
will be coming to Game Pass later in the
month on March 21st what do you think
about GTA 6 potentially not releasing
for another two years let us know in the
comments we'll see you here for more
Gamespot news
[Music]
thank you